Kem cho!
That means “how are you?” in the Indian
language Gujarati.
I understand it fluently but I don’t remember
learning it at all.
So what the heck happened?
Hey guys what’s up I’m Sapna here for
DNews.
Learning a second language is technically
referred to as “second language acquisition”.
That’s because acquisition and learning
are not quite the same.
ACQUIRING a second language is a subconscious
process but LEARNING a language is a conscious
process based on formal instruction.
Both are important.
In 1967 linguist and neuroscientist Eric Lenneberg
popularized the Critical Period Hypothesis.
It’s a theory that proposed the best age
range to acquire a new language.
Lenneberg said the critical period was age
2 to 13- that’s around the age you reach
puberty.
Now, this age range is debated by language
experts and today they prefer to call it the
“SENSITIVE period” instead of the “CRITICAL
period”.
That’s because it’s not SO CRITICAL that
you learn a language during THAT TIME period
only… it’s actually never too late!
BUT research shows there are advantages to
starting early and here’s why…
Kids brains are way better than adults when
it comes to LEARNING because of their plasticity
- their brains are just better at creating
new neural pathways.
It does that through the creation of new SYNAPSES…
the connective junctions where one neuron
talks to another using electrical and chemical
signals.
Shortly after birth, synapses form at a rate
that’s faster than any other time period
in our lives - it’s known as the exuberant
period where a young brain can create up to
2 million synapses every second.
The NUMBER of synapses you have peaks between
the ages of 4 to 8, but your brain still has
a lot of plasticity until puberty.
THAT is why exposure to language at an early
age makes such a big difference.
Now… although Lenneberg’s ‘Critical
Period’ hypothesis states that that the
ideal window to acquire language is age 2
to 13, synapses in the brain’s cortex actually
start forming much earlier than that- during
the second trimester of pregnancy.
And there’s pretty convincing research that
shows language development starts before a
baby’s even born.. so it’s probably never
too SOON for a pregnant mother to speak to
her baby.
And If you are past puberty- don’t worry,
it’s not too LATE either...
Yea kids brains are more ADAPTABLE and better
at making new brain connections but ADULT
brains are better at focusing and better at
complex thought processes.
In fact, adults are FASTER at learning a new
language.
SO aLthough kids are better at SUBCONSCIOUSLY
acquiring a language .. adults may be better
at conscious, systematic, learning.
AND your BRAIN is NOT the only thing that
matters.
There are external factors like who’s teaching
you the language? and are you around native
speakers of that language.
And there are internal factors like personality.
If you’re outgoing you’re more likely
to practice and not be so afraid to make mistakes.
And then there’s motivation - if you enjoy
learning a language or if you really want
to communicate with a hot new boyfriend or
girlfriend.
It sounds cheesy but studies shows you’ll
be more successful!
There is a catch to learning a language as
adult.
The research shows you’re probably not gonna
nail an authentic accent...no matter how hard
you try, you’re going to sound like a foreigner.
But that’s ok because did you know that
being bilingual could make you smarter?
Trace and Alice explain in this video
Do you speak a second language?
Or third or 4th?
If so how did you learn it?
And do you have any advice on what worked
and what didn’t?
Tell us down in the comments section!
Don’t forget to Subscribe to DNews and thanks
for watching!